hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
this discussion of we're going to do
episode six and seven of the Lost of us
as briefly as possible uh but today I'm
joined by two new friends who who is
this I don't know if your perspectives
are the same car who are you hi what are
you doing here you asked me no I'm just
playing
uh my name is Khalif Adams I run the
spawn on Me podcast the premiere podcast
spotlighting people of color in the
video game industry uh and I'm excited
to be here rocking with people to you
and talking more Last of Us and Lucy who
are you what are you doing here how did
you get on this call you sent me a link
man I am Lucy James I work for Gamespot
and giant bomb and you might know me
from the friends of the second podcast
with uh skill up the completionist and
Jake Paul do you know a bunch of great
people
um so first things first how do you all
feel about the show in general thus far
what are your last of us impressions of
the whole season yeah uh they are
nailing this in a way that I did not
expect I was uh you know not not
skeptical if they were going to be able
to pull this off because once you go to
HBO it feels like that is a testament to
where you've gotten from a quality
perspective even before they they kind
of start the show off uh but as a person
who's loved both games and gotten a
chance to stay with those feelings and
emotions for a long period of time like
they're doing fun stuff in the series
that I didn't foresee and it is
connecting me back to that story in a
way that I just you know remembered and
didn't remember because of the new stuff
that they're kind of throwing in that
also elevates it to a certain level of
standard that I think is just so good
right now they're they're killing it in
in lots of different ways I definitely
think they did a very good job of making
sure it's still like fresh for us the
people who played the games and for new
audiences well like I feel like they
fully nailed that oh Lucy how are you
feeling about it I agree I totally agree
I think all of the additions and like
slight tweaks are super super clever but
they are they they know why people
connected to that story into those
characters are they all definitely
playing into
um that and kind of fleshing them out a
bit more obviously the stuff with Bill
and Frank uh was super important and uh
from what we saw from Riley and Ellie in
um the Left Behind episode but like
overall I just think yeah they're
nailing it it is wild how good it is and
I'm just
personally I'm just so excited to have
like appointment viewing TV back again
because it feels like we haven't had
anything like this maybe House of the
Dragon
but I didn't actually watch that one
it's actually really fast yeah I had to
I had to cover Game of Thrones for years
so I I give yourself a break yeah but
like I agree it's so nice to have the
like weekly conversation that we're
having right now I feel like that's
awesome and dude isn't just super nice
to have a good video game but
adaptations like like it's like oh it
can be done oh my God but we're on like
what a trajectory right now because
we've got what Arcane and then Edge one
yeah so animation coverage killing it
Castlevania oh Castlevania yeah and then
live action is like okay well now we're
bringing this to the plate so it looked
good and it sounded good but even like
from episode one I was like what if they
can't do it and then in every episode
you're like thank God oh my God Bella
and Pedro are acting their asses off in
this thing it's like I don't know I've I
had an expectation for what that was
also going to be and I was like I wasn't
as big a Pedro fan because I didn't
really get into Mandalorian all the
other kind of stuff sure uh but he is
ingratiated himself into my my life I
want him to be family now I'm like I
need I need your essence and energy
around me all the time and Bella uh
continues to just like showcase her work
in so many different Avenues and the
emotional range she hits is just so so
good I think like you know the the guy
who gets shot in episode five and he's
like talking about his mom or whatever I
was like damn HBO right and then the
Henry and Sam the guy who played Henry
was just like like one of the best
performances I've Seen On TV especially
considering how small his actual run
time was like how painful that was to
watch he's just yeah the performances
are amazing and I feel like that is HBO
staple
like Craig Craig Matson from The
Hangover
pit stop with Chernobyl which is again
one of the best shows I think that has
come out of HBO I haven't seen it yet I
really need to it's really good but also
be in the right State of Mind for it
it's depressing it's depressing because
it's all it like basically just the
failure of a government and like
everyone trying to cover it up yeah very
frustrating watch but also it's
impeccably made and you know with last
of us as well
very depressing but it does a really
great job of balancing like the human
moments and totally and the jokes and
you know when a couple episodes back
when Ellie gets the joke book and she's
telling each other oh my God my heart
can't take this totally Never Loved A
pun so much
um speaking of the human moments if we
touch on episode six I feel like episode
six is a lot of human moments do I have
my episodes right I do right yeah okay I
do uh episode six is where they actually
go to Jackson and we see Ellie learn a
little bit about Sarah and we have some
of the big conflicts that came from the
game uh play out um in general how did
you guys feel about everything that went
down in episode six
Lucy you go first oh me okay um I mean
episode six was you it's kind of I
realized that the episode's kind of
coming in waves where you have these big
big emotional moments and then you kind
of need like a decompress episode and
episode six for me was a little bit of a
decompress even though the stakes kept
being raised in certain ways I was just
kind of thinking about it because I know
this is not comparable at all but you
know there was a storm in San Francisco
earlier this year and I was like well I
am so underprepared if anything was to
happen What would I miss the most and
then having the episode six where
they're in uh like basically a town and
they kind of get that taste of what it
used to be like and a taste of normality
and not necessarily having to struggle
as much it just felt like I thought the
way they portrayed that was great but
also the human moments with you know
Ellie and finding out about Sarah it was
they still managed to hit even though
they kind of this is the respite it's
still still hit I hadn't considered that
it's coming but you're probably right
that we had a lot of tension and action
I feel like the previous episode episode
five was all tension like 100 of the
time and then we see there's still a lot
of tension in episode six especially
um Joel and Tommy in their conversation
of what we're seeing happen to Joel and
like the conflict between him
potentially leaving I didn't love
um episode 6 as much overall because I I
just felt like and I know it's so hard
to even say if like my brain is even
remembering this correctly but I felt
like some of those Joel and Ellie
moments were stronger in the game
because they had a little bit more time
and I think that that's my biggest thing
about the show so far which is to its
credit that I keep being like I just
wish we had more time with this
um it's it's like tough to care about
something then what should just get
pulled away really quickly or like be
like oh is he going to leave her what's
the thought process behind this and then
it very quickly changes his mind
um but all of their relationship
development I feel like has been pretty
much on point in terms of of pacing
which is like expertly done uh Carl how
did you feel about episode six oh sorry
Lucy I Was Gonna Save The Reunion as
well between yeah and Tommy was that was
beautiful right yeah like such a good
moment of of that yell that he Tommy
like oh my God like finding him and
seeing that he was alive and and all
those kinds of pieces and it did have a
lot of those kind of like tamped down
moments where it felt like oh for for
this one piece of time they feel safe
here and it felt nice for them to as a
viewer to say oh my goodness you have
people here who understand how this new
world works and they're giving you space
to kind of live in it if you choose to
so it does kind of lean into what you
talked about Alana with the kind of sped
up version of what we get with the show
where I'm just like oh man like there
was a space here to kind of let it let
it sit and linger for a little bit
longer than I had hoped for uh but I
just remembered and pulled away from
like all those little little strands of
things of you know just seeing all the
kids kind of sitting around in the movie
theater and hanging out and watching the
movie and I was like even right now I
feel like with the pandemic still
happening those moments I still have
been Stripped Away from us in a way that
still I'm longing to get back to in a
weird way so like Jackson in the game or
in the movie or in the show and real
life they also had this interesting
parallel there too saying like man there
is uh still I still want to feel safe
where I want to go and feel like those
places are still there it's super
interesting that this was like
technically in development before the
pandemic and that it hits so differently
now like we have such a different
context of it all now yeah which I guess
I appreciate like it's it's
it was so depressing when The Last of Us
Part Two came out at the time that it
did yeah um but almost to its credit
like it's so burned into my brain how
awful I felt playing through some of
that game well how awful I felt in a
studio apartment like it's so rough and
I think this is like feels a little bit
more reflective and I love The Slice of
Life stuff in episode six where like
they do keep giving us the opportunity
to to be like hey this is what life
would have been like because Jackson
isn't something that we really had that
way in um part one obviously it's in
part two right and it was nice to see
how like how spot-on accurate it was too
it's so blown away by the set design
like so much of it is so incredible I
haven't read it yet but I know this is
for episode seven but like they did do a
deep dive into how they recreated them
all and I really hope if they haven't
done one for how they did Jackson I
would love how do they do the like you
didn't I haven't read it yet I think it
was on Verizon
I was like how did they get all those
Brands is that a real mole because they
had an A W which I know is Canadian and
I was like well they did shoot in Canada
it was it a real a w like it's just just
looked amazing like mind-blowingly cool
um
how did you all feel about some of the
conflict that we had between Joel and
Tommy in terms of like all this like you
used to be a bad guy they're really
trying to paint Phil was evil in a way
that I feel like is a little less
prevalent in the game unless I'm
misremembering how did you feel about
that uh
Joe was such a man in this episode he
was such a dude and I was like yo use
your words fam like I know you have
things Tony Soprano advice just go to a
therapist dude we were like looking at
them we were like yo use your words like
you you found your brother
and the way that you are trying to
disconnect yourself from him after
you've done nothing but bemoan and and
and talk about how important it was for
you to find him and now you have him and
you're pushing him away instantly that
felt a little bit weird in terms of the
writing and also kind of felt like that
isn't the way I would have thought that
that connection would have gone both
from what we see what we saw in game and
this kind of you know uh Gap Gap filler
between you know uh the story of what we
know and what we played uh so that part
was a little bit worrisome and it also
in in weird the way that he kind of
spoke to Ellie in a lot of those
sections in the moments too where it was
like again we understand that you have
the mission we know you're trying to
disconnect from you know having an
emotional relationship with with this
person who you don't know who you're
supposed to take care of but also you'll
use your words fam yeah you gotta talk
to her like she's a human being and not
just like roll around and be in your
dude dump for no reason it didn't make
any sense to me it was stupid oh I I
think I it's totally frustrating but I I
feel like I find that frustrating in a
way that's so credit to his character
like it makes sense that he's still that
defensive and closed off and I've had a
ton of frustrations with Ellie
throughout the show that I think have
like slowly been alleviated especially
through episode seven where I've been
like why is she so harsh
um and I get that she's a child of of
effectively like a global catastrophe
um but if I had a random grown man I
didn't know walking me through the
Wilderness I would be very nice to him
like right I would be excessively polite
and maybe uncomfortable like I'd be like
I don't know this dude at all what's
gonna happen like this is stranger
danger to a Max and she's like so rude
to him it's like I don't know dude we
had different childhoods I guess
um but I feel like episode seven
to jump forward contextualized Ellie uh
in a really really fantastic way and I
think this is Bella Ramsay's like most
um impactful performance yet like she
absolutely killed it
um yeah yeah so before we do Jump Ahead
there yeah uh Lucy did you have any
input on how they handled Joel in
episode six and and some of those
conflicts there
I mean no nothing going to be on what
car said like it's it I mean kind of a
classic dude thing is to lock down when
things get a little bit too heavy and it
is kind of like frustrating a little bit
as a viewer of just the show to watch
because you're like why is he doing this
you know we thought Joel was better than
this and then ultimately like at the end
of the day he is human we know what is
coming and I guess they're kind of
laying the the groundwork for some
upcoming stuff a little bit but
ultimately it's
I thought it is still like really well
portrayed and just the way that everyone
else calls him on it and just like
pushes him I think is really really
important that they don't let it lie and
you know stuff's changing so much for
them and you know he's he's spent 20
years waiting for it to see his brother
again well maybe not that long but a
good amount good amount of time and then
it's kind of it's kind of again a nice
human moment where I could not see my
sister for a couple years and then we
would immediately be like hey good to
see you miss you love you and then it's
oh my God you know like kind of go back
into the familial stuff so I I kind of I
get it yeah but also yeah come on Joel
I just I did feel like they were very
um
excessive on talking about how much of a
bad dude he was in a way that I don't
remember being there in the game but I'm
not sure like everyone's like he's he
was up to bad stuff and it was like
Tommy didn't forgive him and I was like
I'm not I I imagine that this is
alluding to his his decision at the end
being more impactful because
I'm not really I'm not really sure I'm
unsure it was they were very thorough
with it probably yeah it is because like
I guess in the in the show they're not
killing
as many people as you end up doing in
the game but I think you still need to
have some base awareness that Joel is a
badass and he has done a bunch of stuff
as far as I remember in the game it's
very like front loaded
when mostly when you're with Tess yeah
you're kind of you know the the
unwritten uh history is there but I
think maybe they are just setting
something up for the final yeah for for
Joel too it feels like his his
reputation precedes him in a way that
doesn't make sense either where it's
like he's a bad dude I'm like but you're
all the way over there how do you know
he's such a bad dude if there are some
more people so many more people in in
the space as they saw when they kind of
went to the house and found the folks uh
to kind of find out where time he was uh
so that also is a little bit weird in
the way that they kind of have framed
that for for everybody else in the story
too so yeah I definitely need to pick up
on that too it definitely leads into
season two a little bit
more softly I guess yeah like if they
set up that he's
got some [__] coming
what the hell they're gonna tackle that
while it's I'm almost excited it seems
so challenging especially for a TV
audience like mm-hmm
I just started replaying it yesterday
actually oh part two yeah yeah it's it's
I haven't played it since you know
summer of 2020 and I was like I'm into
it now yeah it's it's I've been playing
through part one again in time with the
show and it's been really fun to do that
because I hadn't played part one since
it came out not to completion so it's
what like
10 years yeah it feels like it's such a
long time and it's it's really
interesting watching the two side by
side and how they make different
decisions and like obviously the
decision not to go to the school and
have the bloater which is the part that
a lot of people really love but it
didn't it's so video gamey yeah like the
hanging upside down thing is like that
that almost ruins some of the dramatic
tension of the show and I can understand
why they didn't it's to the credit that
you know they know what they're doing
they put it that way
um so Jump Ahead to episode seven I
somehow missed a lot of people seem to
know that this was going to be a left
behind episode I didn't know that um are
you watching the trailers at the end of
each no yeah that's why
mystery solved
no I didn't realize but I was I was kind
of Happy not to and it was an
interesting like mirror of episode three
where it's you know it's a different
timeline we're seeing a different story
and
um I really did like the way that it it
fed into
who Ellie is and why she is the way that
she is and the way that they paced it
for all of the issues I had with her
being overly harsh or whatever I was
like oh yeah you paid it off which I I
guess I always thought that they would
but I felt like um they really Justified
a lot of a lot of what
a little what comes out of my mouth the
amount of sass she has I think
um so how did you feel about episode
seven oh it was so good it was it was
like Lucy talked about that kind of nice
respite in in in the kind of you know
ups and downs of what the series has
done so far it was it just brought back
so many good memories of that DLC and
and and understanding that like this is
a coming-of-age story in both the good
and bad ways uh and it was nice to be
able to see you know Ellie and Annabella
kind of like go through the process of
working through that and it did round
out the character a lot in terms of like
you know this is a person who has talked
about loss but then you don't really get
to see some of that because it is
something that happened in the before
times right so you wind up getting to
see that loss happen in real time in
real space with her then kind of you
know becoming the the Ellie that we are
starting to see you know uh flourish in
in those spaces and become that that
badass ugly that we that we know is
coming
yeah so it was nice to see that
interplay between those two and then
also just those really you know kind of
intimate moments and there weren't many
because Joel is of course injured and
hurt at this part of the show
um but even that small moment that they
had are they hold hands where they hold
hands and and there's a let go of some
of that Gruff because he has to
uh was nice to see too and again it just
it just reflects back the like wonderful
performances that they're both you know
nailing on this so yeah it was really
dope it was expertly done in the game
the timing of this the shift of like oh
[__] now I have to care about him
um I think that like it's such a
testament to the Lost of us and how good
the game is that some of these things
are really really similar uh and I I
love the handoff of like now she has to
cast she can't pretend she doesn't care
anymore and it was a really interesting
way to do it like I I didn't even know
that they would tackle the Left Behind
stuff at all um and again I love seeing
the slice of life things like what life
is like in this world in ways that we
couldn't really see so much in uh the
game or if we were just stuck to Joel's
perspectives they did one really weird
thing that I that I is very TV which is
that last scene where they're you know
holding hands she's sewing them up and
they do the like guitar swell thing and
I was like no don't do the guitar small
thing no listen they were also really
noisy and that mole and it took them a
long time yeah
I'm trying this thing
because you make any noise and they're
like yeah yeah
not here
uh Lucy how did you feel about episode
seven I really loved episode seven I
didn't say that about every episode I
know but like I I think the thing that
really got me is obviously getting that
Ellie backstory just kind of getting
more of an understanding of just how
crap her life was like is essentially a
kid in military school being told you're
either gonna be this or that and your
life is prescribed for you and then
having the only joy in her life which is
Riley just vanish and she's thinking
that Riley's dead and then only for
Riley to come back and give her the most
amazing night of her life and that is
genuinely you know you can say that but
it it would have been the best night of
her life ever
um
only for that again another okay well
I'm moving to Boston I'm moving out of
Boston even and then no I'll stay with
you
and then now we go we got bit it was
such a roller coaster and it was you
know punctuated by these really
beautiful and fun moments but ultimately
my heart was just breaking for Ellie the
whole time yeah it was just devastating
is that how it happens in the DLC I
don't remember is it that she leaves to
joining the fireflies and then comes
back after three weeks was that part of
it I don't think it was but I don't know
I don't remember oh God so long yeah I
know it definitely
yeah I think she does leave yeah because
it is
like I like that we saw Ellie before
losing Riley because I was a little like
are they just gonna make that the whole
Crux of a personality she lost someone
because sure loss changes us but not to
this extent so I like that we also see
her be like a kind of bratty shitty
teenager before she even realizes she's
immune like she was always a little bit
like that and then you know she loses
the one person that she really cared
about who she felt how to back so then
she's got to be hardened by feeling like
she's alone in the world on top of her
also figuring out that she's immune
which makes her feel like she's
Invincible it it all made a lot of sense
I was just so impressed by the way that
they
showed Ellie's journey through that one
episode which I write is consistently
heartbreaking incredible performances
from both actresses I thought um Bella
Ramsay here especially is like for
everyone who doubted her for whatever
reason I never did uh it was this one I
was like you can't doubt that come on
that's the Emmy there's the Emmy yeah
yeah seriously just take it no doubt
we're happy for you
um but speaking of the of the mole yeah
this episode like in terms of the set
just
mind-blowingly cool
I don't I I know this show is extremely
expensive uh but the lighting and again
do they have to get like approval from
every single one of those Brands when
that was GameStop I was like in US
[Music]
it's just so strict because I mean
coming from the UK at least watching the
BBC Brands aren't really allowed to be
on TV really yeah so like on the BBC
they're not really allowed to have too
much emphasis on certain on like brands
in particular because then it makes them
feel impartial
right you know interesting say what you
want about the BBC
um Now ABC in Australia is probably like
that then I've just not noticed that's
super interesting they don't really have
they might have changed it since I've
been gone but I remember you know always
kind of been a bit weird interesting
about it but
it was really strange to see things that
we recognize and I kind of am glad they
did that because outside of it being
kind of cool it I feel like it hits home
for all of us a little bit differently
when it stores that you actually walk
past in a mall especially once because
they changed it to 2013 right instead of
2003 and so that was that was Peak Mall
walking around years that's true
finishing uni just going around and
hanging out and just seeing all those
stores and the malls I hit up in 2010
let me tell you
you were every day as I've seen
the same one it got shut down actually
it was really when I went home the my
go-to after school mall toombul is
closed it really
hurts still safe you probably
I've got it got flooded and so they shot
and I was like I had my first kiss there
two more right
there's a body shop there's no game stop
because we don't have those but
everything just fell apart Man game oh
yeah we had a game as well yeah yeah
game and EB Games oh yeah
um how did you guys feel about the age
difference between these actresses I saw
some people say that they felt like it
seemed like Riley was way older I
pictured it just that Riley was a little
more mature they're only two years apart
technically at least 14 and Riley is 16
I believe
I didn't know there was discourse but
also I looked like an absolute weed of a
child until I hit puberty at like 15 so
the opposite people always thought I was
older than I was so if we had dated at
14 and 16 maybe we would have been the
discourse yeah
it would have been the problem people
wait a minute I didn't really know this
is happening here I didn't I didn't
notice anything either until I saw the
internet
doing as it does but but hang on who was
asking those questions were they people
who were aware of teenage girls and what
they look like that's a great question
or like aware of women in general yeah
good point I didn't study that
oh
yeah the Aged part didn't bother me it
didn't feel like there was a huge
discrepancy that instantly enough the
height differential was the thing that
that caught me more I think that's
probably where it came from because in
the game they would seemed like they
were pretty much almost the same height
uh so it didn't make the the kick the
kiss seem as awkward yeah in the game as
opposed to the in the real life version
of it but it was still you know I think
that that character in Riley you know I
just continue to remember that one
moment where she looks at Ellie and
she's like I'm sorry and it was it was
so many versions of sorry within that
one phrase right I'm sorry that I left
you I'm sorry that I'm leaving you I'm
sorry that I brought you here and now
this is the thing this guy calls us to
die you know potentially in those ways
like so many versions of What sorry
meant in that one moment was
it was really heartfelt yeah really
really good chills thinking about that
cause I was like somebody sorry isn't
that one sorry yeah so many sorrys in
that one sorry isn't that yeah I love
seeing the way that these two characters
because they are very different respond
to what's happening to them like Riley's
very like
sad exciting yeah and Ellie's just
really angry
um pretty much top to bottom and I think
that like showcasing two people who've
come from the same place still having a
massively different Outlook and how they
bounce off each other and how it shapes
Elliot just I really feel like they they
nailed it um I thought they had really
great chemistry I I bought that they
were best friends turned lovers it all
made sense
um and it was really nice to see
there's some stuff that this show has
done that this is like the biggest
nitpick in the world that I like almost
hesitate to say it because people would
be like shut up but sometimes Ellie will
point out things
that are new to her but because the
audience is familiar with them I'm like
we don't need to see her say that like
um so University they just like walked
around and went to schools
um that stuff happens a lot and again
I'm like yeah you've done that 10 times
I get that it's new for her we don't
need to keep hearing it though the
escalator thing I loved because when I
was a kid I thought escalators were
[__] cool as hell
she just got to run up and escalate her
as much as she wanted with no security I
was like that was awesome and it's
really nice to see her be that like
happy go lucky little girl that we don't
really see that much of throughout the
rest of the show I would have I would
have actually lean on it and just gone
the whole time you see people's like
spin on them when they lay in the middle
like I've never done that I'd love to
give it a try yeah almost been chased
away
exactly maybe we should bring a pandemic
back it seems great
we're just gonna take over a mall and
just do what we want instead Rising
everywhere we'll do that
um one other thing that really stood out
to me in this episode was the music we
had some really great 80s songs that was
Take On Me which was awesome which of
course is a throwback to the games as
well and the queue is Just Like Heaven
um which I imagine was a reference to
Ellie herself um and how that plays off
of her but yeah the music in this
particular episode was like so evocative
of childhood in a weird way as someone
who didn't grow up in the 80s like it
was still like I was like oh and me I'm
a kid to take on me for some reason I
hate the stuff that our parents listen
to back then it's like right don't have
a choice big into Aha and Hall and Oates
so like Hall and Oates has shaped me I
love this dude
they're touring right now but they're
touring separately and it makes me sad
wait really yeah because I don't know
why but I looked this up the other day
it's just one Hall and one out
wait did they play Hall and Oates music
I think they do wait what is what does
oats do then besides to sing a
songwriter
[Laughter]
I used to love what they did with
Westworld which was taking taking
contemporary songs and putting them into
you know Westworld versions or
um uh what was some of the other worlds
like the the Raj I think was one of them
yeah making them fit and I'm I love a
good music pick especially with the with
the Cure one on the on the roundabout
right round about Carousel carousels
like a roundabout thing it's just a
roundabout for kids
it makes you think yeah
um no the music was beautiful was
beautiful I was like Blown Away by the
production of this particular episode
and the only thing that I could say
negatively about it is it definitely
didn't feel like a filler episode to me
at all like it was so crucial in the
information it provided about Ellie it's
just that this particular love story
doesn't hit his odd after the peak of
episode three
um I think everything after episode
three because of how good it was it had
has to contend with that award-winning
surely episode uh that I feel like it
almost
let this story down a tiny bit because
the other one was so so so strong
um which is a bit of a bummer but kind
of unavoidable when you have one of the
best episodes of Television ever in my
opinion yeah the third episode of the
show
it's definitely uh hard to follow so
yeah I thought it was was very very good
um and I don't have any problems with
the ways in which it it deviated from
the game personally that said it seems
like none of us remember left behind
that well I gotta go and play it you
mean you're not like throwing your hands
to the sky that they didn't that they
played Mortal Kombat as opposed to
something else no that was cool and I
love that Ed Boon tweeted about it
yeah it must be so cool for him too I
was like he didn't know yeah right
nobody told them beforehand
um yeah I've seen people be disappointed
in this episode as well I try not to pay
too much attention but um I'm not
entirely sure why I did see a couple of
people do the like why they have to make
a gay thing which I love
[Laughter]
she was always gay the whole time the
joke's on you the whole time the whole
time yeah it's
um
gonna be very interesting I think from
this point to see how they tackle these
final two episodes because this is my
the only thing I keep filling with the
show is that I feel like it's rushed
because it has to be like you only have
we only have two left that's wild why is
it only nine
I don't know
are they always nine I don't know
I can't remember I mean they can't get
to the end of that story within two
episodes they just can't
it feels like a lot like really at the
end of episode seven is when we've
properly had these two characters care
about each other but still not
necessarily enough that he would do what
he's gonna do because like episode 8
can't be like hey I'm all healed up now
and I'm gonna run around the rest of the
country like that it can't be that short
to get to she has to find a mentor
some rags and some alcohol
some ships surely oh there was kind of a
shiv in this episode uh in episode seven
which I was like thanks sort of did it
she finally stabbed someone
yeah it feels like we have a lot of
ground to cover before this the finale
which is like kind of scary yeah I
wonder if they're gonna make because one
of the episodes one of the early ones
was
an hour and 15. so I wonder if they'll
be true a bit longer
um I feel like four hour episode
These are four hour episodes can get
away with 90 minute episodes yeah you're
right maybe I'm sure they have the
runtime public somewhere I just haven't
seen it but yeah I'm not sure it'll make
you just play through it it'll be like
season finale go here and go play the
game while you can still can yeah
um
yeah it's just uh I feel like that would
be the whole like we haven't finished
the season yet but the thing that that
prevails now that we are well into the
second half is I wish they had made it
like an extra couple of episodes because
if it were 12 episodes we'd have exactly
the 12 hours of the game
um not that we want it to be one to one
but
there are some things and I'm like we
just have a little bit more and ish hey
uh like a flashback episode of ish and
the sewers was kind of my dream I really
hoped they would do that they did do a
little nod I think they found something
that he'd written but I was like that
story would be so messed up to watch
unfold it's like brutal I think that
what there's like a little nod to that
in episode six
um yeah yeah it's it's got it just has
to have been very hard to do to figure
out what to keep and what to cut and
where to Pace things and
I haven't watched the podcast they're
doing because I wanted to watch through
the whole show first and then watch the
podcast so that I didn't like have my
opinions colored by it but I'm sure that
they give a lot of context on how much
stuff got cut or run times and stuff
that I do not envy because it seems like
it's really really hard
um any clothing closing thoughts before
I let you guys go clothing how do you
feel about clothing
needs more hats
lack of hats lack of hats is kind of
annoying there aren't a lot of bald
people yeah true yeah everyone has hair
I'm a little little biased against that
that's fair too much hair yeah too much
too much hair yeah uh in the spot I mean
it is it is just like this continuation
of all of the the the set pieces that we
wind up seeing that I think excites me
for every week of like what are they
gonna pull in that I have a recollection
of that will be that Touchstone that I'm
like oh that was that thing I remember
that thing uh so that was been pretty
good and the little Easter eggs that
they kind of keep popping in and out
like even when they were in the federal
office and he was having the
conversation with with Ellie about that
stuff him putting down his keys into
being a naughty dog logo on the keys oh
yeah that was so cool I was like oh you
cheeky [__] yeah
uh so that stuff is is cool just again
like every week it is musty TV at this
point like I it's regulated to be like I
am going to watch this and figure out
what the heck is going on yeah like Lucy
said earlier it's so exciting Nick to
have that be a thing again and like text
people about it and do this like it's it
is really nice to have and like almost
sad that it's gonna end in two weeks
obsessions back that's true for the last
season I think yeah last season exciting
um
I just love it I'm I'm so I'm like I'm
just impressed with it I think that's
the the main takeaway is I'm so
impressed with how they've done it and
also just that they've thrown everything
behind it none of it feels half-assed at
all and it's hitting with the audience
that is beyond us which is very very
exciting and I think everyone in it
knows how good it is and they're all
just coming at it with their absolute a
game and so I can't wait to see what the
last two episodes of this season are
gonna be like because
I mean it's almost just like the darkest
stuff in the show in the game Sorry and
so I'm just very like I have the
confidence that it's gonna be good it is
nice to have the confidence yeah I felt
that way the whole way through that like
even in the beginning I was like I don't
really buy that relationship I was like
they could do it and you're right it is
it is just very good it's very nice and
I have faith in it and it's it's fun to
be on a journey uh like this if
something that we find familiar and
knowing it's in the right hands every
episode is is really really nice and I
think like episode seven I felt was
really well written I imagine there are
some challenges for writing two teen
girls in an apocalypse when you're a
grown man but I feel like it was super
well written I think Neil wrote this one
actually
um but I'm super impressed by it and you
know funnily enough this is actually the
only episode that I feel like could have
been slightly shorter but uh to add
other things in would be my I would have
had a little bit more of jaw a little
bit less of but that's it only just
occurred to me so clearly I don't feel
very strongly about it
um two more weeks uh I will have this
show up everybody but
um to say goodbye to this week's guests
it's called where can people find you
what have you been up to yeah check out
uh more spawn on me where we started off
our 10th year of of podcasting uh yeah
it's wild uh you can check that out on
every podcast platform on the planet and
check out some of the fun stuff we're
doing there we just finished our award
show the spotties as well so go check
that out on YouTube for our second year
of doing that uh and I'm sure I'll get
into some more trouble before the end of
the year so you'll find me doing more
fun stuff and hopefully more
collaborations with y'all that would be
really really dope yeah always yeah Lucy
how about you uh you find me on Gamespot
and giant bomb and on the friends of the
second podcast which is on every podcast
platform uh and the skill up YouTube
channel I will leave links in the
description below to where you can find
these wonderful people thank you both
for joining me and I will see you all
next week bye
bye